Filmmaking is a tricky business.
It's a long journey from the script to the
screen, and a lot of great and not-so-great
scenes get left on the cutting room floor,
costing the studio time and money.
Here's a look at some of our favorite films
whose deleted scenes came at a high price
— creatively and financially.
World War Z's darker final act
World War Z didn't just trim an expensive
scene or two — this movie's entire third
act was gutted and replaced in post-production.
In the theatrical ending, the movie concluded
with Brad Pitt's Gerry Lane wandering around
a research laboratory and discovering the
scientific solution to all the world's zombie
problems.
But in the original shoot, things were supposed
to be a lot grimmer for our hero.
Before the revisions, Gerry and his sidekick
Segen would've made it to Russia to do a blockbuster-sized
battle with zombies and discover a method
of undead-defeat the old-fashioned way.
But there was still trouble on the homefront,
as his wife and children were in North America,
and she'd turned to prostitution to provide
for her family and ultimately shacked up with
his former colleague, played by Matthew Fox.
This would've culminated in Pitt's character
questing across Siberia to make way to his
now-estranged wife, leaving room for what
would've been a full-on trilogy of World War
Z films.
But the studio wanted a happier ending for
the film and brought in a bunch of new creatives
to rewrite and reshoot the third act.
And everything else, including almost all
of Fox's parts, were left on the cutting room
floor, never to see the light of day.
Not only did Paramount lose the money they'd
already spent for the clipped scenes, but
the re-shoots ended up costing a whopping
$25 million as well.
And that, friends, is what you call a pricey
pivot.
Rogue's scenes in X-Men: Days of Future Past
With its crazy time-travel plot, X-Men: Days
of Future Past is packed with familiar faces,
but unfortunately, that means limited screen
time for some of our favorite characters,
including Anna Paquin's Rogue.
The True Blood actress spent a week filming
several elaborate scenes for the 2014 blockbuster
alongside fellow X-Men vets, but none of it
wound up in the finished film.
Director Bryan Singer told Entertainment Weekly,
"Through the editing process, the sequence
became extraneous…like many things in the
editing process, it was an embarrassment of
riches and it was just one of the things that
had to go."
After fan outcry, Singer and 20th Century
Fox released a Rogue Cut of the film on DVD,
restoring 17 minutes of previously cut footage
that included Paquin's sequences.
The original tragic ending of Little Shop
of Horrors
If all had gone as director Frank Oz and screenwriter
Howard Ashman had initially planned, this
1986 adaptation of the Broadway musical wouldn't
have ended quite as happily.
The pair intended to use the ending from the
stage version of Little Shop of Horrors, with
Audrey II eating Audrey and Seymour and terrorizing
the world — but test audiences hated it.
"Feed me."
"Does it have to be human?"
"Does it have to be mine?!"
Oz recalled to Entertainment Weekly, "For
every musical number there was applause, they
loved it, it was just fantastic…until we
killed our two leads.
And then the theater became a refrigerator,
an icebox."
In order to get the movie released, they needed
better audience approval, so the elaborate
23-minute sequence, which cost a reported
$5 million, was scrapped and a new ending
was shot with the two leads alive and well.
Though a black-and-white version of the original
ending was included on a 1998 DVD release,
full-color footage was finally included in
a Director's Cut edition Blu-ray in 2012.
The Jitterbug dance number from The Wizard
of Oz
The Wicked Witch uses a lot of different tactics
to try to stop Dorothy and her friends in
The Wizard of Oz, but one never made it into
the final version of the film.
In the lost "Jitterbug" sequence, Dorothy,
the Scarecrow, Tin Man, and Cowardly Lion
travel through the Haunted Woods only to be
attacked by evil bugs that cause them to break
out in song and dance.
Also a popular dance style at the time, the
"Jitterbug" was actually a remnant of an older
version of the script that was tossed out.
The whole number cost about $80,000 and took
five weeks to shoot, but it was cut when producers
decided the film was too long.
Though the actual footage was destroyed, composer
Harold Arlen captured a dress rehearsal of
the number on video, later included as an
extra on the DVD version of the film.
Who knows?
Maybe the original footage will turn up in
a studio storage space like Dorothy's old
ruby slippers did.
Returning to Krypton in Superman Returns
Before DC and Warner Brothers decided to reboot
the Superman franchise yet again in 2013 with
Zack Snyder at the helm, Bryan Singer's 2006
entry starring Brandon Routh as the Man of
Steel flew into movie theaters with...fairly
mixed reviews.
Superman Returns also nearly arrived with
a completely different opening sequence.
While the basic plot of the film deals with
Superman's return to Earth after a five-year
absence, Singer shot a wordless, visually
stunning five-minute opening sequence with
Routh's Superman visiting what was left of
his home planet, Krypton.
The scene, which cost an estimated $10 million,
is slow and contemplative rather than bombastic
and exciting.
Maybe that's why producers ultimately had
Singer cut it.
The scene was finally released as an extra
on the 2011 Superman Anthology Blu-ray set,
further dividing critics and fans on the one-off
superhero flick.
Eric Stoltz's scenes from Back to the Future
As most Back to the Future fans know, Eric
Stoltz was originally cast as Marty McFly,
the puffy vest-wearing teenager sent back
to 1955 in a souped-up DeLorean.
Director Robert Zemeckis initially wanted
to hire Michael J. Fox, but his Family Ties
shooting schedule was too demanding at the
time, and he hired Stoltz instead.
Five weeks into filming, Zemeckis and producer
Steven Spielberg knew they needed to replace
Stoltz because he just wasn't funny enough.
Zemeckis and Spielberg quickly negotiated
with Universal to replace Stoltz with Fox,
adding a reported $3 million to the film's
budget and extra time onto its shooting schedule.
Soon Fox was on set at the Twin Pines Mall
shooting with Christopher Lloyd, and the rest,
of course, is history …
"Great Scott!"
"I know, this is heavy."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!